alert major developments on multiple
fronts after an extremely successful
trial period maduras coronavirus vaccine
is now ready to enter the final phase of
testing we have other vaccines also on
the horizon we'll have full coverage
this is remarkable
maybe by the fall record-breaking
progress our medical a-team dr. oz is
here tonight also breaking tonight the
twenty20 election has now officially
changed in a dramatic in a big way the
president is now vowing to take actions
in American cities with war zone like
conditions but the bumbling barely their
corrupt Joe Biden is now embracing well
the most radical socialist wing of his
party we're going to explain in detail
how this is a sign between Bernie and
AOC and Schumer and Pelosi he's
embracing this out of weakness I'll
explain he's also now by the way willing
to redirect funds away from the police
that of course become the enemy defund
law enforcement or to use his words or
will reallocate the monies we're gonna
explain that coming up tonight in a
report plus we'll show you what is the
late latest cringe cringe worthy
blunders from the Biden basement
campaign spoiler alert he now thinks if
you're in the great state of Arizona
apparently you don't live in a state you
live in a city according to Joe the
forgetful one first we do start with a
developing story surrounding a garbage
so called newspaper we have an
information crisis like we've never had
in this country before in this case the
New York I call a toilet paper times
because that's basically all it's good
for they have been exposed yet again now
they are facing a brand-new lawsuit from
Liberty University
by the way Liberty has told me and
they'll join us tonight and just a
moment Jerry Falwell Jr and what is a
powerful defamation suit filed earlier
today the university is blasting the New
York Times for intentionally false
reporting this stems from their hysteria
filled coronavirus coverage alleging
that Liberty suffered a corona virus
outbreak when the school Rio
it's campus after spring break according
to this lawsuit prepared by attorney
Michael Bowie and two separate headlines
The Times all but accused Liberty of
willfully spreading the deadly virus
quote Liberty brings back students and
the coronavirus to and a university
reopened and students got sick the paper
even reported that nearly 12 students
became sick with kovat 19 symptoms in a
separate article The Times accused
Liberty University President Jerry
Falwell Jr of creating his own personal
viral hotspot in reality the truth at
the time zero on-campus students were
diagnosed with Kovan 19 not a single one
12 not 11 not 10 not 1 0 now remember
the same paper remember they're the ones
that basically accused your truly of
killing Grandma and Grandpa because of
our coronavirus coverage when we were
way ahead of them especially and the
rest of the mob in warning people about
the virus and asymptomatic people that
would spread the virus and supporting
the travel ban ten days after the first
known case of corona
it was the leftist New York Times let's
look at their track record they're the
ones that ran the headline who says it's
not safe to travel to China the
coronavirus travel ban is unjust and
doesn't work anyway I wonder how many
people took their advice and what might
have happened to them if they did don't
forget the same paper it was criticized
by its former top editor Jill Abramson
for quote making horrible mistakes left
and right and of course this lawsuit
comes at a particularly troubling time
for that paper the New York Times now
reeling after getting clobbered in a
scathing editorial out this week by
another former top editor her name Barry
Weiss and she recently resigned after
months of workplace harassment hostility
over she's not a conservative at best
I'd say centrist views willing to listen
to the other side views far left x
employees calling her a nazi and a
racist and a liar and a bigot others
demanding she be rooted out of this
organization while post posting axe
emojis next to her name in public forums
Wow
Weiss wrote the far-left Twitter had
become the ultimate editor of the New
York Times whose concerns are profoundly
removed from the lives of most people a
perfect example of what I call and why I
define the modern media as a mob the
fake news media mob is now 99% of news
outlets media outlets smears lie slander
libel besmirched bent conspiracy
theories hoaxes here there and
everywhere truth telling non-existent
they're all about advancing the far-left
radical socialist views of this new
extreme Democratic Party and they have
outright contempt and hatred for all
things President Trump and by the way
all of his irredeemable deplorable
smelly Walmart shopping supporters like
me and for them truth facts reality none
of it matters but in the real world
world actions have consequences
tonight Liberty University is holding
them accountable